どうもインテリ
昆虫ハンターはじめしゃちょーです最近
動画でたまに上げてるんですけども私
ヘラクレスオオカブトを飼い始めてから
ですね結構
昆虫
昆虫に興味を持つはじめまして
元々好きなんですよ昆虫小さい頃から
虫とか育てたりしてたんですけれども
案の定殺し間違えました案の定あの
ちょっとその
失敗しちゃったりしてダメになっちゃった
時とかも結構あってもちろん今はその
ヘラクレス育てる時は色々こう調べたり
勉強したりプロのブリーダーの方からお話
聞いたりして知識を得た上で育ってるって
言ってるんで大丈夫なんですけれども
やっぱそのヘラクレスを育てていく上で
やっぱ昆虫愛というものな日に日に増し
てってもっと昆虫のことは知りたい
ヘラクレス育てる上でもっと学べることが
あったら学びたいと思いまして人生初
昆虫ショップに来ました
そして今日カメラマンは
昆虫大好き生き物大好きついですよろしく
お願いしよろしくお願いします苦手です
全般苦手なの人間以外の生き物がダメで
虫もダメです
けどね
これを機に
根性好きになって帰りましょうなるほどと
いうわけで今日来ましたこちらの無視者
っていう
昆虫ショップに来たんですけれどもなんと
ですねいわゆる
昆虫関係の
百貨店みたいなデパートみたいな感じ
らしいんですよ何でも揃うんだってここで
[音楽]
その生き物生態もいるかもしれないし総合
的に見るとなんか日本最大級レベルの
昆虫ショップらしいですすごいよそうなる
とちょっと行ってみたくなっちゃって今日
来ましたちょっとうちのヘラちゃんのため
になるようなものがあれば嬉しいしもっと
買ってみたいっていうせっかく設備ある
わけじゃん各シェルター他に何か使えそう
なのいたらちょっと買いたいなとかも思い
ながらちょっと行ってみたいと思いますで
は行きましょう行きますね
します
すごくねすごいお
邪魔します
店長さんよろしくお願いします
よろしくお願いします
俺のヘラクレスの師匠平岡さんが鑑賞し
てるこれのね俺の師匠この人師匠です
ここまで言ったらマジですごいですねこれ
がいわゆる最大級の
昆虫ショップということですっげえ
昆虫ショップというのは来店する
初めてですかそうですねペットショップの
昆虫コーナーとかにはよく行くんですけど
もう昆虫ショップっていうの初めてですね
そう見てこれ
標本にする用のこれ針だった気がするそう
なんです
虫のサイズによって太さが違うんですよ
[音楽]
太い方に向かってすごいな
育成とか以外にもそういう
標本にするとかっていうのも結構強いって
ことですよね
魚ではない
すごいドサイズ感緑は
保護色みたいな感じで白だと飛んできた虫
に正面から向き合うとなんかやっぱ避け
たりする
んでしょうね
[音楽]
ちょっとこれ目つけておきますすごいよ
こんな雨見たことないよ俺虫網って言っ
たらもう小さいイメージだもんねこれ多分
あれだ
標本用の標本箱ですよね
めっちゃ好きなんだよねこういうの
ちょっと
ヘラクレスまだあ今ヘラクレス
育ててましてはいちょっといい個体ができ
たら標本にしたいので死んじゃった後も
標本に飾ればずっと楽しめるからね
ちょっと見させていただきますすいません
お邪魔します見て本の数この書物
[音楽]
多いですね
めちゃくちゃ増えてるこういう本も
ちょっとあれなのあーもう本当すごい
最大限オブラート
ミヤマクワガタが770円で売ってる
失礼します
あーでもすごい
ミヤマクワガタだ
指揮者指揮者してるなこの子お前元気だな
すいません申し訳ないすごいほんと
たくさんいるなここがクワガタゾーンです
ね
[音楽]
ガチャガチャコーナーだどういうことこれ
めっちゃ可愛いカブトムシのガチャガチャ
がある
うわー俺小学校の時こういう広告めっちゃ
見てたな
行かんかったけど行く気はあったんだけど
ちょっとバスケで忙しくて行けなかった
記憶があるなガチャガチャもすごい
種類がありますね
[音楽]
めちゃめちゃありますなんか最近すごい
ですよね
店長僕は声帯が好きですよ
動く方がかっこいいですすごいキー
ホルダーもこれかわいいな
本物が入ってるんでマジですか
サソリだ
と久しぶりだぞサソリにそんなテンション
上がんないです
え待って
すごいすごい
スマトラスペクターベリースツヤクワガタ
ラコダールツヤクワガタかっこいいな
これメスかな
子もいますね
すごいなぁ
もうね店長俺この気温でわかるんですよ
適温ですね
隠しリターで育ててるんですけど
20度から25と絶対保つようにしてます
人間がちょうどいいぐらいが虫もベストだ
と思います今度大事なのよ
[音楽]
23とかじゃないですか
24.9上の方がちょっとやっぱ
熱いんです
下の方が冷気下に下がってくるんで多分
23ぐらいありがとうございます
ヘラクレス部屋でもう温度感じるから何
°cだろって
時間ぐらい
ちょっと見てこうこれはもう日本のオス
ですねかっこいいうわ俺これ見たことある
ぞ何かでクワガタだ
ノコギリクワガタのアッシュなのかこれ
角の形すごいぞって結構人気じゃないです
か
[音楽]
昔はあんまり人気なかったんですよ
ムシキングのカードになってから聞いた
ことある
世の中に認知されて整体のものすごい人気
がよくしないなんかお話で聞いたんです
けど店長
ムシキングの人だっていう
最初の時に監修をやらせていただいて
やばい人なんだよ
ムシキングなのよ
すごいですねあれからもうなんか
虫の知名度というか
認知さた一つのきっかけというか出来事
だったそうですよねいまだにカード集め
てる人とかいるからね今年なんか20周年
記念でそうですね結構イベントとか
各地でいやもう1回稼働していくねーかな
そうなんだよ機械だけ動いてて
触れなくてこう電源は入ってるんですよ
もう最初は
セガの人から死者に電話かかってきて
ヘラクレスオオカブトと
ギラファノコギリクワガタどっちが強いん
ですかと買ってきて
どっちが強いんですか子供かなと思って
なんとなく答えてそういう電話が10回
ぐらいかかってきた結構ずっと毎日毎日何
日間当たってで途中でちょっと僕もピクッ
てきちゃって何なんですか
質問どういう
意図があるのかって聞いたら
実はちょっと
虫を戦わせるゲームを作って
我々は素人でどっちだか強いところお電話
で本当大変失礼しました一応お店の方に
伺ってちょっと色々詳しく聞きたいんです
けどみたいなところからそこから正式な
オファーが話しててちょっと
素人だから
監修みたいなことをしていただけませんか
いやすごいですよ
歴史を変えたゲームですからねでもセガの
人も僕もですけどゲームとしてこうあんな
に流行ると思ってなかったんですよね第1
弾とかに結構もう強い
虫みたいなポンって入れちゃってなんか
3段ぐらいになった時にやばいんじゃない
インフレの
加速がねバランスとか先のことは考えて
なかったと思うんですよ
途中ですごい苦しくなってました
だからそこに入れる
組み合わせがなかった苦しくなっちゃって
種類決まってますからね
見させていきますね
ギラファでめっちゃ盛り上がっちゃったね
でも名前は聞いたことあるでしょ多分ね
結構もう
ムシキングの強キャラだった記憶がある
かっこいいのよ
[音楽]
二股クワガタすごい浮気しそうな名前です
けど
ちょっと高いの探してみたいねどうせだっ
たらいやかっこよなんで
ブラブラ
二股クワガタちょっとまた大丈夫そうです
かこれめっちゃかっこいいクワガタって
やっぱこういう曲線美なんだろうねこの子
に17,000円のクワガタですすごい
濃いの見たらちょっとあのヘラクレス愛が
ねちょっと
浮気しそうになっちゃうねクワガタの良さ
感じちゃって
かっこいいローゼンベルグ黄金お肉
クワガタゼリーに頭突っ込んだまま寝て
ますね
俺これ結構買おうとしてたやつなんだけど
これ
菌糸ビンですよねそうですねクワガタの
幼虫って山に行くと枯れ木みたいのに入っ
てるじゃないですかその
借り切ってある特定のキノコが付いてるん
ですよねそのある特定のキノコを人工的に
こうがくずに培養してクワガタこれ
ヘラクレスて使います
ねカブトムシはカブトムシのマットで
クワガタ
専用ですなるほど
高くてなんかどうかみたいな話をちょっと
だけ聞いたことがあるんですけどそんな
ことはないですか
ちょっと新しすぎるかもしれないですね
グズグズになればカブトムシでも食べれる
んですか基本的にはヘラクレス用のマット
で買った方がいいと思います水分多めです
よね水分はそうですねクワガタよりは若干
多めだと思います
ありがとうございますよかったちょっと
最近気になってたので市民すごい種類ある
なぁ
カブトムシクワガタの魅力ってこういう
容器こういうの並べておくとめっちゃ
かっこいいなって思うのよねかっこよくね
こういうのなんか横に並んでて
腰痛とか座ってるのを見るとは
育ててるなっていう感覚があるから
かっこいいこれロングのブローだはい
プリンカップ
使いやすいやつですね
待って安くね店長これ値段大丈夫ですか
近くのペットショップ300円とかだった
んだけど見て値段187円
[音楽]
プライス
爆買いしてっていいこれ何このサイズ
こんなのもあるんだ
[音楽]
何このゾーン皆さん見てください
黄金に輝いてます何これ
虹色クワガタ
これひっくり返ってる
[音楽]
玉ねぎを
置いときたいな
うわーすげー虹色コアだから
めっちゃかっこいい色すげーどういう色し
てんだこれ
それすごい種類いるな
うわかっこようわでけえ店長が飼育したの
でか
店長
飼育したやつだからサイズがさ他の子と
比べてももう
めっちゃでかいのよこの子だけ
[音楽]
いやーすげーテンション上がるなこれ
マットだ待っときましたマットもう
カブトムシと言ったらねマットよ土があっ
てなんぼでしか土で決まると言っても過言
ではないので
ヒラタクワガタだパラワンキラとクワガタ
クワガタ森川手出しちゃうんかな
お店長の議事録画型
でけえ歩きです
今んところめっちゃ高そうなのやっぱ店長
の虹のクワガタですねペアで税込で
38500円4万違うかっこいい
夢の国かそしてカブトムシゾーン来ました
ここがカブトムシゾーンかでかっこいい
グラントシロカブト白いカブトムシですね
[音楽]
これが日本を代表するカブトムシ
2人とものたれてます
[音楽]
いやかっこいい角3本
悪魔的かっこよさあるねかっこいいこっち
にもコーカサスオカルトがいますね
待ってでかくね
でかくねこれすごい乗り上げ方してるな
その木に
可愛い
めっちゃ種類いますね
[音楽]
男の子好きだよねっていう感じでクワガタ
とかもまだずらーっとたくさんいますね
これ全部見せてたら時間ないねすごい数
いるからちょっとつまみつまみ見ていき
ましょうやばい一生いっちゃうこれ
来ましたヘラクレスゾーンですここに行く
とでっか
ちょっと待って待って
見てこれ
俺んちのよりはるかにでかいうちの子には
申し訳ないんですけどもはるかにでかい
ですそしてこれすごいのが値段が
7万1500円
[音楽]
いい決闘なんだろうねそういう大きくなる
血筋のヘラクレスなんだと思います
165mmでしょこれやばいでかいぞ
いやーかっこいいねこのサイズまで行くと
この値段言っちゃうのかいやーかっこいい
ねうちの子ねこれぐらいのサイズだった気
がしますやばいなあかっこいいいろんな
やばいうちの事比較しちゃうこれ
授業参観に行ってる気分ですね
16,500円レアなカナブンで1万円
超えちゃうんだペアだけどえやばいやばい
やばいやばいいる
もうこれやばいわ触覚の長さが全てを語っ
てる26400円
ついこれ見ろ
[音楽]
これですねいやいや
わからない
すごいお花が動いた
あもう足から食べてるんですねこれも
すっげえ
[音楽]
ハナカマキリ見えるくると思わんかったの
知ってるはずなカマキリ初めて聞きました
よね結構
珍しいですね白いランの花に
対しているという白い花の上で待ち構えて
構えるんですよマジでわからんかったなぁ
世界ありがとうございますここもいろんな
道具が置いてありますね
ラックボックスワイドだ俺これ僕も買って
あります横から観察できるからねすごい
映像
向けというか使いやすい
ゼリーもすごい数ありますねクリア
スライダー
[音楽]
容器も本当にすごいなすごいこれコバエ
防止用の
ケースとかも売っていますいやすごい
素晴らしい
感動するわこの
品揃えは
虫だけじゃなくて道具とか土とかそういう
のも品揃えがもうかなりすごいですねこの
ミスでかくね
この店大きいな
やばいなマジでちょっと
欲しくなってきちゃう店長質問です今販売
してる一番高い整体はどの子になりますか
多分このヘラクですよね
これすごいよね
角も結構太めでかっこいいなぁこれが
ナンバーワンだなやっぱヘラクレス人気
ですかそうですねやっぱ
夏はヘラクレスはやっぱ高くて
買えないんですか
[音楽]
成虫のオスメス買って1週間で卵を産み
始めて
し始めてるそうなんです
楽しみですちょっと楽しみですね
緊張しますねこっからどうなるのか
蛹になってからがやっぱ難しいですか
そうですね
蛹になってやっぱ大きければ大きいほど
羽化失敗みたいなのが
多くなっちゃうんですよねそうなんですね
小さい個体は結構きれいに帰るんです
材料を打ったりするの失敗したりとか
大きいとなんかそれだけ体のバランスが
ちょっと
良くなかったり
失敗して不可不全って言うんですけどそう
いうことが多くなったりする場合が多い
ですね難しいなぁ結構動画とか見たり調べ
たりすると逆に腰痛の時食べなすぎても
良くないって言うじゃないですかそのまま
蛹にならないとか
拒食みたいなこともあります
ここからなのよ俺も実はちょっと
たくさん買ってってもいいですか
ちょっと整体はまだヘラクレスがいるので
あとやっぱこの難しくポイントなんです
けど買ってさ静岡に帰るわけじゃ今からと
いうと帰る時の車とかが暑かったり寒かっ
たりするとそこで死んじゃったりするから
むずいんですよね
移動が子供が自転車で来て買ってカゴに
入れて公園で遊んで家に帰ったら死ん
じゃったみたいなダメです
なんかすぐ帰ってねそうですね今
めちゃめちゃ暑いんでカゴに入れてこう
走ってるだけで多分下手すると死んじゃう
かもしれない直射日光が当たって相当危険
にさらされるから車で来てたら良かったね
今日整体は今日はやめときますまた来させ
てくださいですから行きました本当に買っ
ていいですか
ゼリーはマジでパワフルなやつ食わせてる
から
ゼリーは大丈夫なんだけど俺このスプーン
買おう
幼虫とか
怖いからこういうスプーンですくって
あげると結構安全なので
追加で買いますあと何買おうかな
ラックボックスはちょっと買いたいかな
ブラックボックス買おう買います2個ほど
買っちゃいます
すげえこれすげえよこれマットプレスって
言ってこのマットを固めるっていう卵を
産む時とかってねもっと固めた方がいいん
でこれ買います
すごいぞ
[音楽]
これメスってなんかちょっとしゃべるとき
すいません
[音楽]
プリンカップとかでいいと思うんだよね
幼虫たくさん出るようにちょっと小さい
容器が買っておきたいね買いますやばい
[音楽]
籠いっぱいになっちゃった
これ
欲しいな店長さんこれで買えますか
いろいろ
組み合わせがあるんですよね
組み合わせ
柄の長さとか
枠の大きさとかなるほどなるほど皆さんが
よく使われるのはこの2.5m
なんですけど
武器武器いけそうですね
これにします
[音楽]
組み合わせで
虫取り網を作るという必要性をたくさん
買っちゃうんですけどいいですか店長お
願いします
虫だと思ったらwi-fiだった
26490円26490円
マネージャーさんお金借りてもいいですか
すごいなぁこれすごい
虫買いたくなった
もうちょいっす
たら大げさかもしれないですけどそういう
レベルで使えると思いますこれですか
切れちゃったりとかそういうことはあるか
もしれないですけど
枠も竿も
丈夫なものなのでみんな買って本当に10
年とか普通に使ってます一生ものの
三つ編みを買ってしまったちょっとこれで
山行ってきますわいやもう多大な成果を
期待してますありがとうございますまず
爆買いの人でも
ありがとうございましたどうもありがとう
すごかったもう
虫の種類もですしやっぱ標本ゾーンとか
書籍とかまた次は車で来た時ははい
ちょっと虫
探せにくださいありがとうございました
どうもありがとうございます
[音楽]